check out science friday's bumbling of
the trans legislation coverage
of course i did check out science
friday's bumbling of the trans
legislation
and then the question is which media
outlets will talk honestly about this
topic
um yeah not many and oh my god
sarah silverman came out on the wrong
side of this this week
um like i just feel like this is one of
the most
obvious this is one of the most obvious
issues that we are contending with as a
society right now
well actually a number of the things
that we have talked about today
remind me of this basic principle which
is that
uh certain stories diagnosed the system
right right the fact that the new york
times and actually the mainstream press
couldn't figure out what to do with the
evergreen story diagnosed
the problem right if all you had to do
was diagnose the problem with the media
right all you had to know was what
actually happened which is fascinating
you would expect the media to be all
over it because they like fascinating
stuff right
um they weren't all over it oh so
there's something going on there that
makes this story impossible to report
okay so that tells you what's going on
and
the trans story is exactly this right
you have a genuine and very broadly
shared
desire to be compassionate that then
quickly runs into
trade-offs right am am i compassionate
with
people who genuinely find themselves
feeling that they are trapped in the
wrong body and want to transition i
very much want to help such a person i
get what that would be like and it would
not be easy
right on the other hand do i want women
protected from
predatory men who want to avail
themselves of a protected status
yes i do and there are more of them
but it's a more generic story so the
point is you can see
how people who have some simple
heuristic trip
over this and find themselves saying
something in order to defend
one or the other category and they can't
see the nuance and but i mean it's also
this feels even simpler like to me
men who self-identify as women without
even
any requirement for hormones or or
surgery and therefore get to go into
women's crisis centers
and and prisons is really obvious
um lee a problem but you know
you know some number of those men are
just looking for a you know a better
situation
and some number of them really do
suddenly realize that they feel like
women
whatever this one seems even simpler
like the trans legislation thing that is
being talked about i assume although i
haven't
seen this particular coverage is about
trans women in women's sports
it's about sports which you just have to
have been
on the planet for i don't know through
puberty
to recognize that men and women are
different
and um you know maybe you need to have
thought about it a tiny bit
to recognize that actually all that
stuff
that has been making the male pathway
and the female pathway
pathway different since literally since
fertilization
is not reversible with a simple switch a
simple toggle of you know some puberty
blockers and some hormones and even some
surgery
no not reversible it doesn't work that
way well
okay this is obvious to us and it will
be
hopefully obvious to anybody who's paid
attention to what we've said on this
topic
for any length of time but you can
imagine
the problem is heuristics right people
are used to navigating by heuristics and
the fact is
people do it because heuristics are in
general so freaking useful
right but in the case that
let's imagine you were having a dinner
party right
a hundred people and some of those
people yeah
sorry it's a hypothetically you're not
gonna have to do no one has 100 people
dinner parties in this century i don't
think
that's not at dinner you're right that's
like a wedding you're right
all right let's suppose you're having a
dinner party
with three people it's more by style
yeah no totally it is for your style
yeah now let's
let's imagine it's 20 people okay you're
having a dinner party
right i'm having a dinner party 20
people
i'm invited and i may come okay it's
barbecue
because i can do that yeah um but all
right so
the point is there's a dinner party and
every one of your guests
saved two my guests save two
uh are totally on board with
treating our trans friend who will be
present
uh exactly as they would hope to be
treated
right and then did i say two friends or
exceptions
you did and we have two friends who are
overly fond
of you know the kind of uh
uh ben shapiro approach to this where
they're
you know aggressive about pointing out
the ways in which
transness is not a complete
transformation etc okay right
and the point is you can imagine a
desire to get everybody on board with
the majority in that case
and their willingness to behave uh
kindly towards your guest being nice
actually gets us where we need to go in
this situation the right thing to do
right and so the point is okay we can
see the situation also our bathrooms are
already co-ed spaces
they're really single-person spaces well
this is the point like these things
don't scale so people imagine your
dinner party and then they're like well
right so that'll just work it happens we
don't have a prison
our bathrooms work for either sex
right it doesn't you don't even have to
tell us what sex you identify
as when you go in no signs on the doors
right exactly so this is all very simple
it's just a matter of getting everybody
to behave in the same courteous way okay
then you build a heuristic from that and
the point is look
treat people how they want to be treated
it's the right thing to do right it's a
good heuristic until you get to sports
prisons and all of the other things that
force you to actually engage a deeper
question what's going on with sarah
silverman she wrote a heuristic
right that heuristic has now been gamed
and well but she also and maybe maybe
this just came after the heuristic you
may be exactly right but
um i i think i just saw like a 30 second
clip of
of her going off on this this week in
exactly the wrong position
um you know she says well you know why
don't we segregate sex by height
it's like okay you you are
con i think that there's a conflation of
individual versus population level stuff
but
if you're really arguing that we
shouldn't be segregating sex
i mean sport by sex and that is just as
artificial as segregating sport by
height
i think i may have misspoke last time
then you're arguing for all coed sports
which is the end of women in sport at
least at the professional level right
like
you know because because with a very few
exceptions like
maybe long distance running like super
long distance running like
hyper long distance running like 100
miles men will out compete women
in in feats of you know raw power and
speed and strength they just
will and you know like why don't we
segregate sports by height well like
um you know some some sports effectively
do
you know like basketball effectively
does and they sideline everybody
basketball sidelines everybody who isn't
tall and boxing does
segregate by weight yep right right and
so it depends it depends on the sport
but in
every case again with the maybe maybe
possible exception
of extreme long-distance running um
there's just
there's differences and if you don't
segregate by sex then that's the end of
women's sports and is that really what
you want
well i can't remember where it happened
it may have been in one of the patreon
discussions or it may have been
on dark horse maybe in a q a but i
actually believe
that this topic is going to
bring about the end of
sport as we know it because these
questions actually are difficult
right so if you know if you
in the original case you have
a genetic lottery you get whatever
endowment you have genetically
then you make whatever you can of it you
get good at things you develop skills
um you innovate new techniques whatever
and that is exciting to see
play out on a soccer field or whatever
right who's really good at this game who
knows something other people don't know
who's you know better at intuiting the
dynamics on the field whatever it is
right but
and then you get to doping right oh well
i can take what i was genetically
awarded and i can augment it in this way
i can borrow from my future self and i
can enrich myself in the present by
doing it literally enrich
right and so i can basically cheat and
then there's a arms race about can you
cheat in such a way that we can't see
that that's what you're doing
but it you know the point is we're not
in kansas anymore at the point that that
takes over your sport and then you get
into questions about well
why don't we have height classes and
have
four basketball leagues is a game of
short people playing
against you know on a court with short
baskets
less exciting what if they're more
talented that could be really
interesting
right and so the point is you get into
this never-ending
sequence of like well what really is
athletic talent and the point is well
one thing it is at the point you're
parsing how much of it is genes and how
much of it is economics incentives and
all of this thing is it's just a lot
less fun
so i wonder if it isn't all going to
come apart
as a result of this and if you know i
don't think that means it's the end of
athleticism i think what it means is
athleticism will be reborn in
probably a more interesting way and i i
i would put on the table
you know olympic gymnastics
those are really talented people doing
something really boring
right it's like sort of exciting to see
that a person can do that but it's very
hard to distinguish one
routine from the next that subtleties
you have to be an expert to detect most
of them right
and so the point is well the the
sorry the distinction we've made before
is between that and
and watching a great parkour routine
exactly and the point is
you can't compare two parkour routines
in the same way it's subjective but once
you sign up for okay i accept that it's
subjective
it's much more interesting and very
demanding i mean this
we should do a whole episode on this or
more but you know there's a difference
between sport and athleticism
right because athleticism isn't
inherently competitive and sport is
and so like athleticism plus competition
gets you to sport
and um some of the things that we
have in the olympics for instance have
seemed to many of us for a long time and
you know we're hardly the first people
to point out it's like
is that really sport like does
competition really belong there
and if so like on what basis is it being
judged and
you know maybe it just you know i i we
went to um was it like the x games is
that what it's called once not the x
games that's wrong
um the the like the the games once
uh with a lot of like it was parkour
and it was bmx bikers and
um skateboarders and you know outside in
san francisco once many years ago
camera what they're called um this is
obvious but um
anyway um yes they were being judged
it was there's no simple metric right
like this is the
with regard to competition the world
wants a simple metric a simple
linear variable speed um
you know speed down the hill uh number
uh you know speed down the hill
or speed through the thing in
combination with this many
jumps or this much time in the air like
that you just add metric after metric
after metric
um but at the end of the day it's like
okay those four guys who just did that
were all awesome
and for me watching those like i never
care about like who is declared the
winner but of course in order for
the market to work and for there to be a
game for us to go see
a competition for us to go see there has
to be someone who's declared the winner
whereas
you know basketball uh with an
established height
um which no isn't three feet lower for
shorter p
i don't know how much you would have to
be lower you know a foot and a half
lower for shorter people
would be a different game could be it
could be an interesting game
but then then you have to start imposing
height limits right yes
and so you know there really is a
difference between
play and sport and sport and athleticism
and we conflate them all and
the fact is that men and women are going
to have different facilities and yes
some sports really give themselves to
um co-ed i mean i have talked before
about
ultimate how much we both love playing
ultimate and like i specifically having
played
competitively on women's teams and
watched at those same tournaments
a lot of men's teams and played a lot of
uh co-ed
always preferred the co-ed games they
were just more interesting to be part of
always and it's structured to work
structures
don't dominate the women in those games
even though the usual athletic
comparison
still applies yes yes exactly but some
some games
some kinds of sport some kinds of games
won't work that way yep
no most don't most don't um i will say
just
my last contribution here is that i do
think we have kind of a societal
pathology surrounding what you were
discussing
with respect to our desire to have a
metric that we can exactly compare
yeah and you actually see this in lots
of places
you know if you follow cameras and you
watch the absurd
there are certain things it's reduction
dominate right
but that you know i i realized in
teaching
specifically because evergreen freed us
to do whatever we needed to do in order
to get the job done
that actually there was a uh
a world open to us
once you accept the subjectivity of
evaluation and the fact is i don't think
what i was doing was any more subjective
than what mostly gets done but
people have this pseudo-quantification
mechanism
where you know well you're going to turn
in an essay and then i'm going to give
you
you know points out of a hundred and
then i'm going to put the number in my
book
and then at the end of the term we're
going to count those numbers and the
point is
i don't know if most people use numbers
for essays but
whatever they do yeah it amounts to
pseudo-quantification and the point is
as long as you've got a layer in there
that's subjective your thing is
subjective
yeah now if you don't own up to that
yeah right
this is huge i mean this is a second
vastly important topic
one of pseudo uh quantification and one
in which and
i think the more enumerate you are the
more easily you are fooled when numbers
are
presented to you and so the more likely
you are to think when you get
presented with like here's a ranking
here's the answers
here's what the data say um and you're
like oh
well there's numbers this must be the
truth like actually
um often though none of that was
legitimate because there was some trick
somewhere in there and sometimes it's
intentional and sometimes it's not
often people just don't have any idea
that you can't
you you can't turn those subjective
things over there
into numbers and then and pretend that
it was quantitative all the time
the whole time right and the thing is
you know basketball is kind of objective
if you've got referees it's all done in
public the referees judge
the rules the rules are known to
everybody and how many times you know
within the rules the
the ball goes through the basket
dictates the number of points so
that isn't one of these things but so
many things baseball nor
soccer or football right right so
those things are not of this nature but
the number of things that
are subjective and pretend to be
something else by virtue of some
hand-waving argument for making them
objective is
shocking and the degree to which things
get more interesting once you say okay
subjectivity that's part of this one
yeah it doesn't
it doesn't make parkour less interesting
to watch right right
it's subjective but wow are those people
talented and
that's some pretty amazing stuff you
wouldn't think you could do yeah
[Music]
you